well at its essence the Playboy brand
stands for sexy stylish lifestyle and I
think that that's been sort of its
eternal core and fortunately for us has
given it really global appeal so whether
we're extending the brand through
multimedia or extending the brand
through licensing into lifestyle
products that's really what it stands
for I think when you're responsible for
a brand a great deal of what you have to
decide is both what you do with it and
what you don't do with it because every
action you take under that brand you're
in effect either making a deposit or
withdrawal from the brand bank account
if you will and miss steps are you know
withdrawals and there's a limit to
obviously how much you can do that can
you know be not helpful to a brand and
still preserve the brand's inherent
equity